on en cours face à cette maladie la
grippe aviaire dont l' oms a dit cette
semaine je vous le rappelle qu'elle
pourrait tuer jusqu'à 100 millions de
personnes dans les années qui viennent
la france se tentent de s'organiser les
aéroports sont en train de s'équiper de
caméras thermiques qui de thermique qui
prendront en quelque sorte votre
température à votre descente d'avion en
provenance d'asie nicolas chateauneuf
sans le savoir ces voyageurs de
l'aéroport de pékin se font prendre la
température
le secret cette caméra thermique qui
mesurent la chaleur corporelle sur
l'écran de contrôle chaque couleur
correspond à une température précise le
passage est normal et bleu celui atteint
de fièvre apparaîtrait en rouge en
janvier prochain les aéroports de paris
testeront à orly certaines de ces
caméras car en cas de contamination par
le virus de la grippe aviaire
le principal défi est de repérer
d'isoler les malades le plus rapidement
possible
objectif éviter à tout prix une épidémie
car si cela se produisait la france
compterait de 9 à 21 millions de cas ils
hôpitaux devraient gérer jusqu'à 1
million d'hospitalisations et l'on
pourrait compter 212 mille décès dans
tout le pays dans les cartons le plan
d'urgence prévoit la généralisation des
soins domicile la fermeture des écoles
la restriction des déplacements et même
l'interdiction des grands rassemblements
et comme on n'est jamais trop prudent
les autorités sanitaires ont déjà
commandé 13 millions de pilules
d'antiviraux